yeah and you may not recognize many of
the names of the players involved
because the attitude will be next man up
sometimes you have to be ready for
whatever comes your way including peter
king not hearing me today although we
have a workaround that will be put in
place a very high tech workaround
involving producer matt casey telling
peter what i'm saying
as i say it until peter can actually
hear me but hopefully peter will let me
know when he can hear me maybe he hears
me now peter i got you mike i can hear
you now here we go here we go you know i
was kind of looking forward to two hours
of of uh of the challenge
of doing a show without peter hearing me
all right but peter you're right we're
going to talk coming up about some of
the developments of this week as it
relates to the nfl's ongoing effort to
play pro football in a pandemic on one
hand it is amazing that we're on the
brink of week 13 and all games have been
played yes several weren't played when
they were supposed to be played but they
have been played with five weeks left in
the regular season and the nfl i agree
with you has a determination to get
every game in to check every box of one
through 256 and then progress to the
postseason with 14 total teams for the
first time ever in the field the
steelers will have to get through the
remainder of their regular season
without
linebacker and excellent pass rusher bud
dupree confirmed torn acl out for the
rest of the year it's unfortunate beyond
the obvious it's an injury that is a
grueling rehab that takes away from the
steelers one of their best defensive
players and keeps bud dupree from
playing for the rest of the season but
also the timing is horrible peter
because bud dupree was in a franchise
tag year
months away just three
from free agency and now a wrench has
been thrown into that because no one's
going to give him the kind of contract
that he was earning on the field while
he's rehabbing from a torn acl so
financially it's a disaster for dupree
and from a football standpoint obviously
it hurts a team that is undefeated and
is trying to finish out the season 16-0
you know the thing about bud dupree is
that i think with all the attention paid
to tj watt and rightfully so
um you know he clearly is a top three
candidate for defensive player of the
year
um
if you watch the steelers regularly
which which we do you see that bud
dupree
is you know roger maris to mickey mantle
you know he's a great football player
he was the best player on the field when
the when the steelers opened the season
and struggled to beat the giants
and you know he has been
a terrific presence
mostly on the other side of the field
from tj watt this entire year that loss
is really going to hurt and again look
mike tomlin you know who always is a
next man up guy and coaches are
you know mike tomlin has to understand
now that okay so every team
or every guy on his team starting with
alex highsmith who he says is basically
the next man up is going to have to
fortify the pass rush because this is a
major major loss
and you know the strange part about the
bud dupree time with the steelers there
was a degree of ambivalence the steelers
had toward dupree they went with the
franchise tag because they hadn't
previously through five seasons four
years of his rookie contract and the
fifth year option they hadn't extended
him because they weren't sure so they
went with that extra year of the
franchise tag and now we see what
ultimately happens with bud dupree and
pittsburgh and let me just check my math
here one two three four five he is in
year six so he did finish his fifth year
option for a second i thought maybe they
didn't even use the fifth year option
but they did but they'd never signed him
to a long-term deal and he was on track
to make the kind of money that you would
make either from the steelers uh or on
the open market here is
mike tomlin peter as you mentioned
talking about the comfort level with
alex highsmith as the next man up in
place of bud dupree
i'm just as comfortable and confident as
i was in robert spelaine when we called
upon him or or kevin dotson when we
called upon him on the other side of the
ball
that's life in this business and so
those guys work behind the scenes every
day very diligently preparing themselves
for these opportunities not only in
terms of knowing what to do but just
preparing themselves in terms of
conditioning
for when we ring their bell and we are
ringing alex high smith's bell now so be
exciting to watch him uh respond to it
but it'll also be exciting to watch his
growth because growth is associated with
experience and no doubt in this in the
upcoming weeks he's going to be gaining
a lot of that
tomlin's entire demeanor there speaks to
the cold hard reality of football
guys are going to become unavailable for
a variety of reasons
and you just have to have the attitude
that for whatever reason a guy falls off
the train the train keeps rolling and
there's someone else on the train ready
to take over his job and that's kind of
just the way it is and if you allow
yourself to mourn the loss of a player
to grieve over his unfair circumstances
now that he's rocketing toward free
agency with an acl rehab if you stop to
do that
you're losing sight of what you're
trying to do as the coach of the
football team it feels a little harsh
but it's just kind of the way it is
peter
you know i'll abridge this story mike
because i know i've bored you with it 16
times but it's the classic when i
covered the giants in the 80s and i once
said to bill parcells hey
you're playing without george adams and
and carl banks and brad benson and blah
blah blah this week because of injury
you know what you know and i'm basically
pre-making an excuse for him and he said
peter give me your media guide and he
starts showing me in the history section
of the giants wlw
he said this this 1965
new york giants uh schedule and and wins
and losses when you see it the results
it doesn't say fran targenton was hurt
that day or tucker frederickson was out
that day it doesn't say that it just
says win and loss and he goes nobody
cares
and that's what's going to happen now
with the pittsburgh steelers tomlin's
got the right attitude
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports